this Wendover productions video was made
possible by hover get 10% off your
custom domain or email from hover with
the code Wendover at checkout so here's
the question let's say you hop on a
plane from New York to Amsterdam then
transfer onto a plane to Cape Town South
Africa upon arrival in Amsterdam
passengers just pop out into the
terminal and then reboard the next plane
you never would have gone through
passport control so which country were
you in during your connection the simple
answer is the Netherlands but you
weren't in the same Netherlands as
people in downtown Amsterdam the
international zone of airports is part
of the country in which it is physically
located more or less it almost operates
as a separate country because a border
control agent would say you weren't in
the Netherlands but a police officer
would say you were you were in the
Netherlands in a legal sense but not in
an immigration sense this can create
complications Chinese citizens for
example don't need a visa to transfer
from one flight to another through
Amsterdam Schiphol Airport but they do
need a visa to enter the Netherlands if
a Chinese citizen without a visa commits
a crime in Amsterdam Airport that crime
must be tried in a Dutch Court but if
they don't have a visa
the Chinese offender can't legally enter
the Netherlands the country therefore
has the rather amazing ability to create
a floating international zone around the
Chinese citizen no matter where they go
they are not in the Netherlands even if
they are walking down the streets of
Amsterdam they will never have gone
through passport control or had their
passport stamped but they'll still be in
the Netherlands physically of course
though they'll always be in the
captivity of police officers the
question of which country you're Indian
airports can get a little more
complicated thanks to the USA the u.s.
operates a unique system of customs
preclearance facilities at a number of
airports and some train stations and
ports around the world essentially when
flying from Dublin to New York for
example you clear US customs in Dublin
so that once you arrive in New York you
can immediately walk straight out of the
airport with no further checks just like
a domestic traveler so once you pass
through u.s. customs in Ireland you're
in the u.s. in an immigration sense
but here's where it gets tricky you're
in the US but you're not on US soil
Irish laws still apply pass us customs
in Dublin Airport of course there are
exceptions the US border agents working
the facility are on the other hand
subject to US laws despite being in
Ireland they are essentially treated
like diplomats crime is pretty rare in
airports so this doesn't normally cause
problems but consider this there's a
preclearance facility in Abu Dhabi
Airport in the United Arab Emirates
where homosexuality is illegal and can
be punished with fines prison time or
worse that means that if you got a
little frisky past US Customs in Abu
Dhabi Airport you could technically be
arrested all in the US for being gay of
course this would never happen because
it would create a diplomatic incident of
monumental proportions but the point is
that it could happen
speaking of diplomacy more
jurisdictional fuzziness comes with the
United Nations headquarters in New York
the territory this building is on is
technically international territory not
part of the u.s. in general US laws
apply but the UN can at their own
discretion make their own laws
that trump US law for example the UN
headquarters in New York is allowed to
issue stamps and run their own postal
service for its employees something that
would be illegal in the u.s. there are
more ways to visit countries without
going through immigration back in the
40s Russia and Estonia redrew their
border and ended up making a bit of a
peninsula of Russia jutting out into
Estonia between the towns of Lu Thapa
and Cessna ki as part of the Soviet
Union it wasn't a problem for Estonia to
build a road between the two villages
through the peninsula since the borders
were rather porous when the Soviet Union
fell though the border became one of the
most guarded in the world and therefore
so sneaky was cut off from the rest of
Estonia so Russia decided to allow cars
to drive the short route with no border
controls no paperwork
as long as they don't stop order agents
watch cameras at both end to make sure
that any car that goes in one end comes
out the other and sends an agents if a
car takes too long but this road allows
individuals to visit one of the most
guarded countries on earth without a
visa or even a passport
despite the USS affinity for large walls
secure borders and heavily armed agents
you can legally visit the u.s. without
passing through border controls or
immigration as the longest international
border in the world there are actually
quite a few unguarded border crossings
on the US Canada border but when
crossing one you are still required to
self report to the nearest Border Patrol
station with one exception hider Alaska
has a unique distinction of being the
only town in the southern half of
Alaska's Panhandle to be connected to
the outside world by Road that is though
because it is directly across the border
from Canada given that the only roads
into haider come from Canada and you
can't drive anywhere in the United
States from Hyder there are therefore no
US border controls when passing into
Hyder and there's no requirement to
self-report to a border patrol station
there is however a Canadian border
control station when passing back into
Canada from Hyder meaning you could
accidentally cross into the US without a
passport and then get stuck
Hyder is essentially a Canadian town
stuck in Alaska the residents
unofficially use the time zone of
British Columbia rather than Alaska use
Canadian dollars have Canadian phone
numbers and use Canadian fire and
ambulance services perhaps most
interesting however is that you need a
passport to travel to the United States
from Hyder while it doesn't have an
airport it does have a seaplane base
with regularly scheduled commercial
flights that Ketchikan Alaska even
though this flight is fully within the
same country and state upon arrival in
Ketchikan all passengers are sent
through US Customs
it makes sense the reason Hyder doesn't
have us customs is because there's no
way to get out to the rest of the US but
this flight will be the only time that
you need a passport to travel from one
part of the u.s. to another now for the
granddaddy of which country am I in
questions which country are you in well
in a plane let's say you're flying on an
Irish registered airplane from Paris
over Canada to New York are you an
Ireland France Canada or the United
States this gets super complicated
according to immigration law you are not
in any country just like in an
international airport even though you
are physically in the sovereign
territory of Canada each country sets
its own upper limit to its sovereignty
above earth but all countries have their
limit above the altitude at which planes
fly from a legal view within that plane
you could be an Ireland France
Canada and the United States all at once
jurisdiction for crimes committed in the
air gets really fuzzy depending on their
own laws each country could prosecute
the same crime most of the time the laws
that apply are those of the aircraft
country of registration Ireland in this
case but assuming the plane continued to
its final destination in the US the
arresting officers for a crime would be
u.s. police and therefore unless another
country claimed jurisdiction the trial
would take place in the u.s. under US
law since the plane landed came the US
however Canada could also claim
jurisdiction in 1998 Pan Am flight 103
was brought down by terrorists over
Lockerbie Scotland
of course jurisdiction was a huge issue
especially considering the suspects were
Libya but in the end the trial was held
in a Scottish Court under Scott law
since it was over flying Scotland and
therefore in Scottish territory when the
plane was brought down they got
jurisdiction
however for complicated diplomatic
reasons relating to the extradition of
the suspects the trial was actually held
in an old US Air Force Base in the
Netherlands that was temporarily seated
over to Scotland the rather
disappointing answer to which country
you're in when flying is that it depends
countries will just claim or ignore
their jurisdiction depending on
convenient
in the end the only way to find out
might just be to hop on a flight and
commit a crime this video is made
possible by hover hover is by far the
easiest best and often the least
expensive way to buy your custom domain
or email there's just so much to love
about them when you call customer
support this happens when you're
conversing speaking they just pick up
and answer your question no holding no
phone trees it's that simple
well I've bought plenty of domains from
hover what I recently started to use
hover for is email using a custom domain
such as Wendover dot productions you can
add an email for as low as five dollars
per year which give you a superbly
professional and unique web presence I
just set up a new personal email through
hover Sam at win over dot productions
which you can feel free to email me at
especially with questions about hover
and I'll do my best to respond you can
buy your custom domain and email from
hover with ten percent off by going to
hover com slash win over hover has been
a wonderful supporter of window
reproductions and they truly do run a
fantastic service so please go at least
check them out and if you decide to buy
once again go to hover calm slash went
over and use the code Wendover for 10%
off if you haven't already please go
check out my new podcast called show
makers where we have guests like Hank
green smart every day vsauce3 and more
check out my last video here and
subscribe to this channel to receive all
my future videos right when they come
out thanks for watching and I'll see you
in two weeks for another Wendover
productions video
[Music]